dié
valérie lemercier vous avez déclaré je
préfère jouer 500 fois un spectacle que
d'aller une fois la télé on vous pose
jamais les bonnes questions être
animatrice jamais ça serait un cauchemar
je préfère me pendre par exemple vous
dites aussi c'est assez finement noter
vous dites quand par exemple tu as fait
quelque chose hier soir non j'ai regardé
la wii on dit je suis allé au cinéma
les petits trucs chez moi enfin si on
invitait plus les gens qui ont rien à
dire il y aura pas de télé vous éteignez
votre télévision et prenez en banlieue
il faut dire que philippe gilbert sera
pas été sympa avec vous parce que votre
première télé il a dit que vous aviez un
physique difficile
oui c'est parfois que non bah je veux
dire qu'ils font
non je trouve très bien là non là vous
êtes vachement bien mais là c'est bien
c'est un prix de diane
non mais c'est pas grave il ya eu
pourtant que vous êtes un peu comme ça
un peu en colère après la télé pourtant
il ya eu un moment de télévision avec
vous qui est inoubliable
donc on va faire comme chez arthur d